today we're unboxing the brand-new 1
plus 60 and if you are new to my channel
welcome if you're not new you guys are
probably like Justine are you gonna make
any other videos besides the videos
about phones yes I will look bear with
me because it is new phone season along
with new video game season which I'm
super excited about I am looking forward
to the holidays because that's actually
what I have free time to play games but
for now we are going to unbox the brand
new one +60 that was just announced I am
so excited about the in screen
fingerprint sensor spoiler alert if you
didn't watch the presentation this is
the reviewers kit that they sent out to
people so let's see what's inside
one plus screen cleaning cloth I will
never turn down one of these things I'm
getting all the things that aren't
things here it is a collection of
individuals possessed by a tremendous
understanding and superior taste and to
find the technology there's something
that I do love about oneplus is that
they do really do listen to their
community and they love the people that
use their phones which maybe like most
companies do but they really do embrace
the fans and I think that's incredible
and I think that a lot of companies
should take notice of that we've got
some accessories I feel like most of you
are here for the phone unboxing so let's
open this up and take a look I am going
to take this outside and take a few
photos I don't like to do inbox things
about actually testing things out are
you suggest to unboxings but I just feel
like I'm giving you enough content like
show us the thing that you just don't
win
box it matches my nails I didn't plan
that actually I swear I didn't oh look
at this a fingerprint sensor in the
screen this is gonna be super exciting I
hope hope fingers crossed that it works
like it should I feel like that's one of
the biggest challenges that a lot of
companies have been having is make the
in screen fingerprints actually work
well look at this notch or lack thereof
you probably see it a little bit right
there I love that they already put a
screen cover on here for you so you
don't have to worry about damaging your
screen this is Ben I thought that it was
gonna be
in the phone but because it has the
curved edges on the back it does give it
sort of that feel that it is thinner
already slugging it up because I'm a hog
hi there while this is setting up let's
unbox the rest of the things so I've got
a nice clear case we've got a USBC to
3.5 millimeter jack I love the red
detail another one of the incredible red
USB C cables and a charging brick Oh a
word from one-plus CEO I'll open it look
he called me friend handwritten
nonetheless I think that he wrote those
handwritten to every single person okay
next up what do we got in here I've got
the bullets headphones we're gonna slice
open ever so gently
well the packaging looks great I'm
always super impressed
you look great okay now let's check out
the cases that they have included all of
those cases are usually super nice this
is the nylon bumper case I like that I
wish this is a maybe like a darker color
though this is the sam tsui this one is
a much thinner case I think it really
depends on like what you're kind of
going for isn't it silicon red one
I love these ones because they have like
the soft interior much like this one as
well so this is everything that we gots
we've got three cases actually we've got
four cases because the one plus actually
comes with the case press and make your
finger cover the fingerprint
identification area as much as possible
to lift after you feel a vibration
there's also a new screen calibration
I'm gonna just stay with the default
it's done it's ready it's here so some
of the new features in the 60 is it does
have the screen unlock it also has a
bigger screen this is a 6.1 inch AMOLED
display pretty gorgeous and obviously
it'd be notch here it's obviously much
smaller than the iPhone and it's
incredibly much smaller than the pixel
three there's also an option that you
can hide it in the display settings and
it's extremely easy to hide it so you
don't have to have any special developer
access show hide in case you missed that
the first time show
hi we're gonna keep it on because it
really doesn't bother me that much a
base model of this phone starts at 128
gigs of storage with six gigs of RAM I
really love the in screen fingerprint
reader I mean it just like it just works
so let's test it out that's probably
like the third time that I've done this
so far and every time it doesn't work
fantastic so stay tuned I hope that I
won't have any issues I know that there
has been a lot of issues in previous
displays trying to make this all work
but so far so good you can also use that
to quick launch apps I'm excited to test
out the photos and the videos because
you guys know that's probably one of my
most favorite things to try out in new
phones oneplus said that they have a new
algorithm that automatically adjusts
photos taken on the front and the rear
camera so if you're taking pictures of
people or food or text it'll
automatically figure out what you're
taking a picture of and try to make it
look as best as possible I've been so
interested in all of the AI photography
because these phones and cameras are
learning the things that we're taking
for Rosa and automatically adjusting to
what they think looks best at some point
I don't even know what looks good
anymore because I'm so overwhelmed by
technology and trying to put photos and
videos side-by-side and figuring out
which one looks best when sometimes you
just have to step back unless I fall
over and appreciate something for what
it is I think that's been something that
I've been working on a lot lately is I
have been so overwhelmed with technology
and it's something that I love and that
I've basically had a passion for my
entire life but it's trying to find that
balance between okay this is something
that I love but now I'm feeling super
overwhelmed by it how do I find that
fine line in that balance between tech
and no tech if you guys have any
suggestions please leave them in the
comments below
speaking of tech let's go back to this
phone because I want to go outside now
and take some photos but before I do
that I'm just gonna kind of go through
really quickly
and I'll just take my first selfie
because why not
we're here people look so dumb taking
selfies like I know it I know I look
stupid but I'm gonna do it anyway
and there it is that's my first picture
put a nice little short film on here for
us to watch for video this shoots 4k 60
and it also does super slow-mo it'll do
to 40 and 480 at 1080p
now that I have unboxed this I've
unboxed all of the accessories I don't
think I have anything else more that I
can say to you here at this desk let's
go outside and test out some of the
photos look at the little animation that
it has when you touch the fingerprint
okay what case am I going to put on it
because if I've learned one thing I just
seen cannot be trusted not a case on her
phone we are out on the hike and this is
the first time that I am trying the
front-facing video on 81 plus 60 so what
do you guys think we're only 12 minutes
in hmm we've got a way to go this will
be third breakfast because I had one
breakfast and then I had breakfast again
so we're doing bubble coffee so we're
getting third
[Music]
Oh
okay we just hit a mile let us focus
that's pretty good there's our friends
up there so this is the back facing
camera for k1x to Exim yeah get that
drink Jen five six eight X you look good
[Music]
no it's not it's not it's that speech
camera 4k how does it look good that's
well I'm asking them oh you're gonna
walk into a bush it's really riveting
content hello on the front-facing not
front-facing not front-facing
rear-facing hey you mess it up every
single time like obviously it doesn't
really matter yeah I'm really actually
really liking this phone a lot so far I
love the feel of it like it's just so
we're having I guess it's sort of a
Halloween party and I have to finish my
one +60 video because it's it's the
embargo is up right now as you guys are
watching this - you guys excited about
starts okay 4k 60 is first so I think
from this earlier and that exciting to
film and it's dark out so we're gonna
put some water into a glass no way yes
has anyone ever done that provide Oh No
get out of town we can't put we can't be
first on YouTube to do this here we go
okay we gotta get it here where
I wasn't recording that brings my 1 plus
16 video to a close with an unboxing and
they last the camera for playing Mario
Party now any Maya party Madi man so
yeah this is crazy look look at the
dodge take it like a little tear drop
way drop that one little raindrop I'm
Madi oh I see the notch they look at the
notch
I want this blanket to be reckoned with
go pay you must be hard spoiler you go
oh ok
happy 1 plus 60 launch day see you later
[Music]